would you rather live one 1000-year life  or live 10 100-year lives would you  rather be illiterate but have the power  to read minds or just have the ability  to read would you rather eat chocolate  flavored poop or eat poop flavored  chocolate  would you rather speak any language  fluently or be able to talk to animals  would you rather have your web browsing  history available to everyone or fart  popcorn  would you rather be able to run at 100  miles per hour or fly at 10 miles per  hour would you rather be 4 foot 5 or 7  foot 7 would you rather have sex with a  goat and no one knows you did it or not  have sex with a goat but everyone thinks  you did it would you rather only be able  to whisper or only be able to shout  would you rather never have to worry  about money or live in a world with  Pokemon would you rather watch your  parents have sex every day of your life  or join in once to stop it  what's the hardest would you rather  question of all-time